THE DAILY BRIEFING WITH
DANA PERINO, ONE OF OUR FAVORITE
GUESTS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
VERY QUICK QUESTION AS SOMEONE
WHO HAS FOLLOWED AMERICAN
POLITICS FOR MANY YEARS.
IS THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE RACIST?
>> Dana: IT'S SUCH A
DISSERVICE TO THE INSTITUTION, .
IT'S BAD FOR CIVICS EDUCATION.
THINK OF HOW MANY PEOPLE FOLLOW
HER ON INSTAGRAM AND THINK, OH,
YEAH.
TO THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS
RACIST.
BECAUSE SHE DRIVES THROUGH A
RULE AREA OF THE UNITED STATES,
SHE'S DRIVING THROUGH FLYOVER
COUNTRY, SHE THINK'S IT'S OKAY
TO SAY THAT THESE PEOPLE DON'T
MATTER.
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE HERE DON'T
WHILE, WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
RULE PARTS OF THE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE URBAN CENTERS.
THERE ALL OF THESE THINGS.
NOBODY SAID IT WAS RACIST UNTIL
RECENTLY.
THEY DIDN'T SAY IT ONE
BARACK OBAMA WON THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE TWICE.
THE OTHER THING IS, WHEN SHE
TALKS ABOUT THIS, NOT WANTING
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE, IT'S JUST
THE NEXT STEP TO SAYING THAT
THEY DON'T WANT THE
UNITED STATES SENATE EITHER.
THEY DON'T WANT THINGS RIGHT.
THEY JUST WANT THE CITIES, OF
WHICH YOU JUST HIGHLIGHTED IN
YOUR A BLOCK, TO BE IN CHARGE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
PERSUADE AND USE ARGUMENTATION
TO SAY WHY THEIR POLICY
PRESCRIPTIONS WOULD BE BETTER.
I AM ON THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
TRADITIONALIST AND EVANGELIST
FOR THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
I WOULD BE HAPPY TO DEBATE
ANYBODY ABOUT THIS.
I FEEL THAT STRONGLY THAT THE
FOUNDERS KNEW IT THEY WERE DOING
WHEN THEY SET IT UP.
MINORITY RULE IS, I'M SORRY,
MAJORITY RULE IS NOT WHAT WE ARE
SET UP TO HAVE.
WE ARE A REPUBLIC.
WE HAD THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE,
AND IN FACT, COLORADO PASSED
THIS LAW, SAYING, OKAY.
WE DON'T EVEN CARE WHAT THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE SAYS.
WE ARE JUST GOING TO DO WHATEVER
THE POPULAR VOTE IS.
GUESS WHAT, TODAY, U.S. APPEALS
COURT IN DENVER SAID, NOT SO
FAST.
THAT DOESN'T WORK IN OUR
COUNTRY.
I ALSO THINK IT'S FUTILE WHAT
SHE'S DOING.
THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE IS NOT
GOING TO CHANGE IN OUR LIFETIME.
THEY WANT YOU JUST SAID THAT YOU
WOULD BE HAPPY TO DEBATE ANYONE
ON THE QUESTION OF THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE.
SHE DOESN'T, AND PEOPLE LIKE HER
DON'T.
THEY SEEK TO TAKE THE QUESTION
OFF OF THE DEBATE TABLE BY
CALLING IT RACIST, IN OTHER
WORDS MORAL.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOUR POSITION
ISN'T EVEN WORTH HEARING BECAUSE
YOU ARE A BAD PERSON, BECAUSE
YOU ARE RACIST, BECAUSE YOU
SUPPORT A RACIST
INSTITUTION.
WHAT DOES THAT DUE TO OUR PUBLIC
DISCOURSE?
>> Dana: IT'S GROWING, BECAUSE
I THINK EIGHT OF THE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATES FOR PRESIDENT IN 2020
ALL SUPPORT GETTING RID OF THE
ELECTORAL COLLEGE.
BUT THAT'S A LOT A LOT.
IMAGINE HOW MANY PEOPLE ARE OUT
THERE HEARING THAT THE ELECTORAL
COLLEGE IS THE VEIN OF THEIR
EXISTENCE?
SHE SAID THAT THIS WOULD SILENCE
VOTERS AND VOICES IN IOWA.
THAT CERTAINLY IS NOT THE WAY TO
WIN BACK THE WHITE HOUSE IF YOU
THINK YOU WANT TO WIN.
THIS IS A SYSTEM THAT THEY ARE
GOING TO HAVE.
I THINK IT'S A GOOD SYSTEM, BUT
I DO THINK THAT IT IS A
DISSERVICE TO SAY IT SHOULD BE
ABOLISHED WITHOUT ACKNOWLEDGING
THAT IT ACTUALLY HAS A PURPOSE.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
EXACTLY.
TO DERIDE IT, DISMISS IT AS
IMMORAL.